hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a thai heist and thriller movie
based on a true story called bad genius
the movie starts by showing a girl named
lin
she is a top secondary school student
and she has been living with her father
all this time
one day her father enrolls her to a new
prestigious school but she does not want
to study there because the enrollment
fee and the other expenses will cost
them a lot of money because lynn is
valuable to the school for being so
smart the principal gives her a
scholarship so that she can study there
while taking photos for her id she meets
with grace a good natured but
academically challenged girl they have
become good friends since then
unlike lynne she is not very smart but
she is quite good in other things like
her acting skills during extracurricular
in her school
in the library she tells lin that the
school has made a new rule
in order to pass the grade the general
average must be around 3.2 as a result
brace tells her that she surely fails
the test
knowing that lynne is a genius girl she
asks her to help her in the test
on the exam day lynn finds out that the
exam is exactly the same as the
questions the teacher leaked in the
private tutoring sessions
she also looks at grace realizing that
she cannot answer the questions properly
she decides to help her by writing the
correct answers on an eraser then
passing it to grace using her shoes they
almost get caught by the teacher but
luckily lin gets over the problem
at the end grace gets a 3.87 gpa while
lynn gets a 4.0 gpa to thank lynn grace
invites her to the pool party so they
can celebrate their good grades
there lin meets grace's boyfriend pat
unlike her pat is very rich
he learns from grace that lin
successfully helped his girlfriend in
the exam
because of this he offers her a huge
amount of money to help him and his
friends cheat on another exam
although at first reluctant lynn accepts
the offer when later she finds out that
the school secretly collected extra fees
from her father who earns a modest
income as a teacher
soon she devises a system of hand
signals based on certain piano keys as
lynn presses the keys each pattern of
pressing will represent the letters a b
c and d
the others just need to remember the
pattern while lynne uses them to send
answers during exams
therefore her base of clients eventually
grows
from the money she has earned she buys
her father a new shirt unbeknownst to
her father she keeps everything a secret
disguising it is just piano lessons bank
another bright student in the school is
lin's rival all along
he also receives a scholarship from the
school because he comes from a poor
family he has a different characteristic
from lynn he is very honest and he does
not tolerate cheating during exams
later he is paired with lynn in a
competition and they are able to win it
after that they are called by the
principal who informs them that there is
a scholarship abroad that they can apply
for
however there is only one slot making
them rivals from that time
when bank gets home it turns out that
his mother has a laundromat then he
learns that the washing machine was
broken so his mother has to wash the
clothes manually
feeling unbearable he offers to help his
mother to wash clothes
the next day he is approached by another
student tom he tells bank that he didn't
go to school yesterday because he was
sick so then he offers bank some money
to help him in the exam but obviously
bank refuses it during the examination
bank accidentally sees tong looking at
lens paper
then he decides to warn her about tong's
behavior on the other hand lin already
knows it because tong is one of the
people who apply to her piano lesson
afterwards bank also warns the teacher
as he submits his answers in front of
the class but the teacher does not care
about it because the test is separate
into set a and set b to overcome
cheating
meanwhile lin finishes her exam first
which is set a as she simultaneously
sends answers to her friends using the
hand signals
while the teacher is not looking at her
she uses the opportunity to exchange her
paper with tong which is set b
she quickly answers all the questions on
set be as the time is almost over
surprisingly she has enough time to pass
the answers to her remaining friends
after the exam she gets caught when bank
warns the principal about the cheating
earlier thus her father is also called
to the school
the principal informs her father what
she has done before
as punishment the school suspends her
scholarship
furthermore she retaliates the principle
by saying that it was not a full
scholarship anyway because there are
other expenses that they had to pay
angered by what she has said the
principal also revokes her chance to
apply for an international scholarship
at university level automatically bank
is now the only one who can apply for
the international scholarship even
though it is something that he regrets
because it costs lin's chance when she
gets home her father is so disappointed
in her causing him to not want to wear
his new clothes again he also tells her
to return the money back to her friends
in the last school year grace invites
her again to participate in cheating
this time it is not an ordinary exam but
an international standardized test for
university admissions called stsc
grace also tells her that pat's parents
want her and pat to study in boston
university so passing the stic test will
prove they are eligible to study there
lynn initially declines the invitation
because it is a very hard test but then
she agrees when she realizes that they
can take advantage of the different time
zones
the next morning they make a brilliant
plan lynn can take the test in australia
where the test is conducted four hours
early then she can pass the answers back
to thailand and sell the answers to
other students who want to take the test
she also tells them that she can
memorize most of the answers
however she needs someone's help for the
rest of the answers because of that she
needs someone who has a capable mind for
memorizing the answers which in this
case is bank besides that she already
knows that bank will refuse the
invitation due to his hatred of cheating
the night before bank takes his
scholarship exam he is attacked by thugs
in the street and he is thrown in a
landfill the next morning which causes
him to not take his exam
knowing about this lin comes to bank's
place and offers him the job
he initially refuses her offer but then
he agrees for the money he desperately
needs that night they make preparations
for the final operation
the plan is that both lin and bank will
fly to australia in order to get a head
start on the exams
during break time they will go to the
bathroom where they hide their cell
phone to deliver the answers back to
grace and pat meanwhile in thailand pat
and grace will print out the answers and
barcode printed on pencils then the
pencils will be distributed to their
clients which in this case are stic test
participants
nevertheless on the eve of their flight
pat slips out that he's the one who
ordered the thugs to beat up bank in
order to force him to join their scheme
feeling enraged bank immediately attacks
pat pat then attempts to apologize but
bank decides to leave in rage
lin who is also shocked at the
revelation begins reconsidering her
actions and chases back
however he returns to confront lynn and
tells her to finish what she started
consequently they continue their plan
later they finally arrive at sydney to
take the test
in the first sections both of them
finish their tests before the break
leaving them with more time to memorize
their answers but during break time bank
suddenly tells pat and grace to raise
his share in order to send his answers
for them pat is reluctant at first but
grace persuades him to fulfill his wish
he then delivers half of the money and
promises that he will give the rest
after bank sends the answers back to lin
and bank they successfully finish their
second sections but there are problems
during their second break the inspecting
officer has caught banks oddity for
staying too long in the bathroom during
the break time
on the other hand lynne ends up late to
send her answers because there is a
queue inside the women's bathroom
therefore bank is caught red-handed by
the officer while lynn manages to escape
carrying her phone and hiding it on her
boots and she eventually hides it inside
a water dispenser she then continues her
final section without bank and she has
to memorize all the answers by herself
because she is running out of time she
makes herself vomit by using a pencil
and then tells the officer that she is
sick
she leaves early as she memorizes the
answers completely
meanwhile the officer who caught bank
also tries to pursue her in order to
know that they are connected while being
chased she is sending the answers on her
cell phone she also almost fails to send
the last set of the answers when someone
bumps into her but fortunately she is
able to do so
afterwards the officer finally catches
her asking her to come with him for
questioning during the interrogation
bank motions her to leave him by denying
that he doesn't know her returning to
thailand lin is happily greeted by pat
and grace and also finds out that their
scheme was a great success but she turns
on them and rejects her share of the
money due to her bad experience in
sydney
they still celebrate along with the
other participants who had passed the
stic test they also tell lynn that bank
already took a share beforehand but then
she leaves the group chat
sometime later she is invited by bank to
come to his place
it seems like he has invested his share
in revamping his mother's laundry
business
after that bank informs her to start
another scheme
he also assures her that this time it
will be much safer in a wider client
base
when she turns him down bank threatens
her to expose the whole affair that she
was another mastermind behind the last
team lynn then tells him again that she
has made her choice deciding to come
clean
later she tearfully confesses to her
father who comforts her and helps her
redeem herself by submitting a formal
confession to the stsc organization
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]